the new DLC for XCOM - called Shen's
last gift lets you bring sentient robots
into battle the hulking machines which
developer fair axis called sparks don't
completely change the sci-fi games
turn-based tactical combat they're
essentially hero units with more health
maneuverability and firepower than the
normal human soldier they're also taller
and more noticeable targets for enemy
Advent forces but they do add wrinkles
to the existing formula they're unable
to take cover for instance whereas human
soldiers can duck behind low walls or
crouched behind semi trailers sparks
don't actually attach to cover but
merely stand behind it this necessitates
much more careful attention to sight
lines than was the case in XCOM two
battles of the past sparks can however
create opportunities for cover
that is by standing in the open or in
the gaps between destroyed vehicles
sparks become veritable options for your
human soldiers to take cover behind they
offer the full defensive bonus and
because of their high health and armor
can take a beating before shutting down
and exposing their human allies sparks
are also surprisingly nimble their
massive metal frames notwithstanding
they each come equipped with jet
thrusters in their heels removing the
need for ladders poles or vines while
ascending cliff sides or building
facades lastly the most subtle and maybe
underrated factor is sparks lack of
human emotions from the eight hours I
played I never once saw spark panic an
enemy sectoid seemed incapable of
exerting their signature mind control
over the robots this was a godsend for
protecting my rookie soldiers who were
much more prone to panic and confusion
in the haze of firefights
the added versatility and spectacle of
sparks overshadows the process of
actually unlocking these robots but this
facet of the DLC is fantastic as well
the necessary mission took me about 80
minutes to complete which to XCOM to
veterans will sound astronomically long
it's a story heavy affair and much more
scripted than most skirmishes but it's
an exceptional mission nonetheless it
jumps from defensive scenarios to
assault sequences with ease there's also
an abundance of enemies as the mission
came to a close and I escaped in my
dropship I had eliminated 52 robots
garnering more than enough experience to
improve each of my soldiers several
times over but perhaps the greatest part
about Shen's last gift DLC is that it
fills out a sixth character role we have
this mark and with our current
technology it always depends on the
situation of course but now you can
bring a veritable Dream Team into battle
with 6 possible character types to
supplement each other it's a distinct
mesh of psychic powers mechanical
strength and human ingenuity and much
like these versatile squads
XCOM 2's new dlc is well worth your time
for the many new features it brings to
the XCOM formula
target destroyed no problem boss